【拍手】
はじめ）ゲームズじゃねえや
は）単数形でしたね
は）私が発明した新しいゲーム
は）というゲームがあるんですけども
は）それを今日は2人でやっていこう
と思います
まさき）はい
は）どんなゲームだと思います？
ま）いや…
ま）「〇ックス」ってなに？
は）まあ ルール説明をしますと
は）お互いにこう 攻撃をターンで
は）やっていくゲームになります
は）僕がたとえば
は）僕がたとえば、こう
は）「〇ックス」って言ったら
は）まさきはそれに当てはまる
は）「〇い」っていう言葉を
言わないといけない
は）例を1つだけ出すと
は）たとえば、あの
は）「(ﾋﾟｰ[規制音])ックス」って言ったら
ま）ははははっwww
は）「(ﾋﾟｰ)ックス」って言ったら
は）「したい」
ま）ははははっwww
は）言った言葉に合わせれば
ま）あーなんか どう、動詞的なね？
は）そそそそそ！
は）「い」で終われば
もう何でもいいです
は）願望とかね「〇〇食べたい」とか
は）「飲みたい」とか いう形になると
思うんで
は）それ以降「〇ックス」「〇い」
は）「〇ックス」「〇い」っていうのを
は）交互にやってって
は）先に出なくなったら負けという
ま）えっ もう、そ…
は）知識力というか、知識力と
は）「〇ックス」に対する知識力
ま）ははははっwww
は）「〇い」に対する知識力が
は）試されるゲームとなっております
は）ではもう 早速やっていきましょう
ま）マジで！待って 俺「〇ックス」が
ま）もう1個しか出てこない
は）「(ﾋﾟｰ)ックス」だけ？
ま）「(ﾋﾟｰ)ックス」じゃないよww
は）止まった瞬間…
ま）やばい やばい！
は）じゃ よろしくお願いします！
ま）はい
は）最初はグー、じゃんけんぽん
は）じゃあ 先攻で
ま）はい
は）いきます
【ﾋﾟﾝﾎﾟﾝ(正解の効果音)】
は）おー、クリアクリア
【ﾋﾟﾝﾎﾟﾝ】
ま）おーー
は）っていう感じですよ
は）そういうこと そういうこと
【ﾋﾟﾝﾎﾟﾝ】
は）うんうん
【はじめ沈黙】
ま）おーーww
【ﾌﾞﾌﾞｰ(不正解の効果音)】
は）はははっww
は）難しいというか 後半が本当に
ま）もう もう俺なに言っていいか…
は）もう無いの？
ま）もう無いんだけどww
【ﾋﾟﾝﾎﾟﾝ】
【はじめ沈黙】
ま）はははっwww
は）…っし！
2人）ふふっwww
は）さあ 難しくなってきましたよ
は）まだ あるんじゃないですか？
ま）ある？
は）ある まだある、絞り出せ！
ま）あー
は）おおー、ほら うまいうまい！
は）ん？
は）マニアックww
ま）ふふふっwww
【ﾋﾟﾝﾎﾟﾝ】
ま）おおー、はい
ま）ああー
【ﾋﾟﾝﾎﾟﾝ】
は）もう 知識力がすごい
ま）確かにそれ
は）いや まだある
【マックスむらい登場】
ま）うわああああ！！
【ED】
ま）マックス
は）むらい！
【マックスむらい登場】
ま）うわああああ！！
マックスむらい）参る！
マ）見たか！
マ）これが大人の10コンボや！！
3人）はははっww
は）ありがとうございます
マ）ありがとうございました
は）ばっちりと
ま）はははっww
は）もう、これがしたかったんだ
ま）うわーー びっくりした